[Music]  researching on it I think I was quite  nervous at first because it's loved by  everyone and it's such a big thing so  the first day on set they made us feel  really welcome and at home I loved the  movie so much you know I was a huge fan  of the kid it's a joy and there are not  many chances to work on a fire movie as  an actor some of you you must have fun  when I guess the most important on the  mall is to be in front of an iconic  character like Jack Sparrow played by  Johnny it was a dream come true to see  him work and interact with all these  crazy characters in this world it was  like theater in a way so I've been in  admire his work for as long as I can  remember and to get to know the guy and  know that he's actually really normal  when nice and you know really thinks  through his character and commit to  being Jack Sparrow so once in a lifetime  thing  [Music]  you  [Music]